in to tell a project for international
understanding through television is a
partnership of reader fusion London the
Australian Broadcasting Commission the
Canadian Broadcasting Corporation
national Educational Television and
the Westinghouse broadcasting
company of the United States
the promoters said let there
be light and there was light
and it came to pass that all the
electric bulbs in all America but
all 800 million of them are made today by
16 men he was found here endeth the first
what you give the nation that has everything why
anything the factories hum with production the
warehouses bow all that remains is to sell it sell
it hard and sell it so we are at the convention of
the suppliers of barbers and beauticians dealers
in brief take it home try to love it because a new
product that sold exclusively in barber shops we
sell hair goods hair accessories sleep caps Karla
caps scoffs scoffs scoffs hair nets wave nets
we come out with the most exciting promotion
in the entire beauty industry which is what we
give trading stamps to the salon operators the
first gear cosmetic situating that part of the
body that has never had the real charm that is
entitled to it kiss proof washes right off
can be used with or without earrings and is
something that's going to change the hairstyle
because it's going to course the women can wear
their hair back off of the ear there's a nice
little item the women are complaining about the
heat they can just random selves just like this
you know that 93% of the people in this country
safe trading stamps and the most important
stamp to that woman who is saving her is the
particular stamp that she's saving that's why
this plan is so unique because nobody else in
the country has ever been able to accomplish
it to give them their choice of trading stamps
Mott's p.m. a delicious blend of apple juice
and grape juice that quenches your thirst and
refreshes you fast nobody laughs at a man who's
got pimple unless he tried to hide him like a girl
if you know how silly it looks when a man uses
a very messy cream that shows on his face come
on mister stop treating pimples like a girl and
fight nipples like a man with MFC that's MFC men
and face conditioner MFC helps dry up temples
fast MFC also helps tie up the oil that often
cause pimples it even helps grow healthy new skin
and best of all MF sees invisible on your face
the only thing that shows is the improvement so
mister if you've got a skin problem don't treat
it like a girl fight pimples like oh man there's
no hiding place now not from the incantations of
the hard sell come to buy the street cries of a
thousand million dollar peddlers endlessly assail
the being of America come by the call of the
hucksters echoes through the land we can't stop
producing so for God's sake concealed by anything
for any reason to pause for breath is to betray
the economy the frontal attack is replaced by the
EM have you registered clear from the stone gate
company yet no I have them oh we're registering
all the girls in this area over here to receive
a beautiful free gift from the stone gate company
and along with that we Marlys want to introduce
our fine hope chest items to you what is your
first name how am i obligated after you registered
well none whatsoever the company all vacant send
out a beautiful little china miniature that you
can keep on your dresser or possibly take down to
work and use for bobby pins or things like that
so a nice little china miniature with a beautiful
pattern on it to Marlys show show you our products
are available at any time that you might want them
what is your first name Rihanna uh-huh what's your
last name Lana Kelly Maya uh-huh where do you live
at Lana 48:46 Normandy I say listen I'm gonna be
working in that area this evening why don't I drop
by on 6:30 or possibly 7 o'clock and drop your
little gift off and maybe some literature and some
priceless and things like that well I'm not really
too interested in Hope Chest items oh we know
this the company understands this but we know that
sometime in the future you may be and we certainly
hope that you call on us instead of somebody else
at that time please don't be so suspicious just a
part-time job with me and of course we take and we
sent out all this little things where you know I
get paid I'm working my way through marriage this
tells a story of your your marriage incidentally
you notice has two bands on it one signifies your
engagement ban the other your wedding band a
little Greek key in here is the bond that will
keep your marriage together of course the white
brilliance to Jessie here will always stay like
that isn't this beautiful this is beautiful
and a nice part about it that you can have it
for as little as no money down a dollar to a week
we'll let you have the entire program tonight as
a first call special for two 99.95 now would you
take this on a budget program or a cash program
budget I see now would you be able to handle two
dollars a week or three dollars a week three three
dollars a week fine we'll set it up on that basis
would you okay that here where I get the little x
mark please it isn't trade it's a vocation calling
for missionaries professional evangelists of the
American Dream invoking all the tender humanities
in the proof that salesmanship is something that
can itself be sold you say what is it's two words
sincere appreciation sincere appreciate you know
what this means don't you it means one thing if
you think somebody can help you because they are
good at something you tell them you don't you
don't do it with money you don't do you just
tell him it works very simply I'm married to a
good-looking gal Molly's a knockout she's been
this way since she was 15 people have been telling
her all her life I've been married to this woman
25 years I've been telling her every chance I get
honey you're the greatest thing since sliced bread
now who does this who does this sincere
appreciation thing and has the whole world
at his feet you know this one you are intimately
acquainted with this one this is the greatest
public relations man on the face of the earth if
the attitude of all these people were that your
dream would be automatically done if you never
made another speech as long as you live the whole
oh by the ears because he does one little thing
you say who is this guy you say I know him sure
your dog you see my dog what does a dog sell well
I'll tell you what he sells everything that you
are beating your brains after iron he's already
got it for free I think everybody in this room
if you're gonna be totally honest with yourself
that I ask you to confess nothing is looking for
a shortcut to success now I'm talking about
success in terms of money and worldly goods
because this is what it is I am aware of the
moral issues involved in this when I start off
this way I know that money is the root of all
evil a forerunner of iniquity I know that my
mother used to say money doesn't make happiness
Robert which is true but I think the fact that my
father was a multimillionaire considerably
helped this philosophy of hers Rockefeller
old man Rockefeller said you can't buy health
with money wasn't he 97 when he ran out of gas
it is fitting that there should be temple worship
of certain virtue and marble monuments to Mammon
in California did William Randolph Hearst
a Pleasure Dome decree the castle of San
Simeon directed from the assorted antiquities
of Europe to the glory of God and of a simple
American newspaper millionaire who exemplified
the first American virtue which is achievement
that is to say getting rich but to be properly
acceptable to the American fairy tale success
had to come through endeavor work as an end in
itself as defined by art customs professor of
labor relations whose father was given a piece
of virgin land we moved on a homestead we got
640 acres for almost nothing as a gift from
the government but we hadn't settled on this
homestead for more than a month before we were
taught that this was the prize for thrift and
and all the hard work and this kind of thing
and during the early years that I lived on the
homestead the one thing that I learned was the
importance of work hard work work that involved
the production of things and when I went to school
the thing that I remember most vividly was a poem
we used to recite in school which went something
like this work worked my boy be not afraid look
labor boldly in the face take up the hammer or
the Spade and blush not for your humble place
this is the doctrine under which I grew up and
I felt this very very strongly along with all my
high school classmates every Sunday when we went
to church we sang work for the night is coming
Coyle was a model composer in those days toil
made sense the early Americans drew life from
the land extracting its meat in its metals
and this was not only necessary it was right
the night continued to come and the work went
on but it was changing and the night seemed
farther away than ever the emphasis Alton
now came production the genesis of the great
phenomenon American industry he demanded new ways
of thought a totally new set of values and they
were hard to find for the values had no roots
and motto now came the day of the engineers in
the assembly line in the interchangeable part
the birth of the most wanted machine and the
explosive discovery that the horseless carriage
could be mass-produced into the tin Lizzie
this was the first American Industrial Revolution
and its profit was of course mr. Henry for Henry
Ford the first who made cars like rabbits make
rabbits in great abundance and for the multitude
on the famous principle that you could choose
any color you lights long as it was black he
triumphantly represented the twin American ideals
ruthlessness and success he stood for the great
article of faith that said business and government
were separate things and never the twain should
overlap and the per genius of the businessman
should dominate the cultural politician
contemporary and comrade afford was that
other article of the buoyant generation Thomas
Alva Edison even more a creator in his own way
since deaf-as-a-post though he was he invented
the gramophone and the printing Telegraph and
exactly twelve hundred and ninety-eight other
such inventions that'll simps so enriched and
bedeviled the world Edison was very much part
of that powerful prosperity he too nudged the
great industrial daydream along its soaring
path and then like an economic earthquake that
abounding affluent suddenly collapsed and broke
like a bubble in the great financial crash of
the early thirties Americans learned in a wounded
bewilderment how fleeting a thing is security
and how far from the frontier they had come
the are as they say produced the man a new
Democratic president called Franklin Delano
Roosevelt himself immensely rich yet notably
understanding of the dreadful dilemma of the
dispossessed FDR's New Deal notion was radically
simple that wealth was basically unstable and
less distributed and that to sell things you
had to have fires that set the pattern for the
affluent society and so through the valley of
the shadow of the Great Depression the American
economy edged back to solvency the system had
not after all let them down the system must
be okay basically working and gaming is the
function of man and the economy resumed its
rocket course - richness to the great abundant
embarrassments of today where the watchword is
brother live now and pay some other time you
can have a brand-new home for the price of
a new car and if you want a lot to put it on
you really haven't made because side Bennett
figures anybody willing to invest in a lot is the
home-loving responsible type and he'll build you
a house on that lot and charge you nothing
down you like that will you hear the rest
they're not prefabs now these are custom houses
these are built to quality control standards and
carefully controlled materials to your local
codes little boxes little boxes made of little
boxes ticky tacky and they all look just the
same and the people in the houses all went to
the University where they all were put in boxes
little boxes all the same and the doctors and
as lawyers and business executors and they're
all made out of ticky tacky and they all just
the same and they all play on the golf course
and drink their martini dry and they all have
pretty children and the children goes to
school and the children go to summer camp
and then do the University where they all get
food in boxes and they all come out the same
and the boys go into business and marry and raise
a family and they all get put in boxes little
boxes all the same there's a green yellow one and
they're all made out of ticky tacky and they all
in the today of the great spending the American
people must be getting credit for one thing for
one thing for everything giving America credit
is a way of life America is built on the economic
axiom that what goes up must come down that
what is produced must be consumed and the
eternal disposability of dollars we are about
to enter the biggest supermarket in the world
to Hebron in the economy of total consumption
money is no object that is not at the time money
comes later for the moment the important thing
is the credit rating which is the citizen's
certificate of solvency the diploma of the
deferred payment for some it is practically
abolished hard cash it makes everything
so easy to have now rather than tomorrow
everything is available when all life is
on tick and when the motto is charged it
you can fly with no change of plane to Guatemala
Panama San Salvador Caracas Brazil yourself Paulo
for Rio and if you want a swing completely round
South America and see both coasts nine cities for
the price of one buy a round-trip ticket to Buenos
Aires as little as 10% down gets you on your way
to any of Pan Am's 15 latin-american destinations
with a boggart Deborah Carr sue lieth in Tennessee
Williams the night of the iguana since man has
known woman that has never been such a night
did you know there's a man right here in town
who actually loves to pay bill other people's
bills he's the manager of your nearby dial
finance office he can save all your bills
and cut your monthly payments as much as one
half helping people solve money problems is
his business and he loves it he's had plenty
of experience at dial and he knows money to
get out of debt is a happy solution to most
people's problems so if you need money dial
dial finance remember you have a friend at
dial and he's anxious to get you the money
his name's overthrows the manager of dials
off the two for the 84th Street in Long Beach
off to live in Long Beach style hemlock 2:7
for a product for jump keep waiting for your
call a heck of a nice guy dial Hemlock
to seven four eight one call right now
friendly just pick up the phone and when you
hear the tone I'll find five five four two one
the argument is that there is no saturation
point there's always room for a bit more buying
another little article or object or service or
amenity or luxury or induced hypnotic compulsion
to acquire what you don't need with funds
you don't have it is known as instant money
or creative indebtedness it is the illusion of
ownership or perhaps the ownership of illusion
the conventions of unreality are however
strict the world of wonderland has no place
for non conformists else I don't live in San
Francisco you know have any idea with me it's
in my car I'm looking for it I've been parked I
parked about two hours ago and I've been walking
around I started looking for it about half an
hour ago I can't remember the street the street
like the area that you were parked in well it
was in somewhere this people on it I was just
looking around Pete - you don't have anybody
just suppose you got in the car and we'll
see if we find your own will be nobody walks in
peatland this is the land where cars own people
but things mustn't last mustn't endure survival
would distort the economy and ruin the Ark of
the Covenant which is production from creation
to destruction is a brief enough span but even
so too long if industry makes X million cars
a year it must dispose of X million cars a
year so that X plus million cars a year can
replace for of such is the kingdom of colors
an old car is an old cop an incubus and
a traitor to the great machine of
profitable progress began dull car
there is therefore a graveyard for automobiles
in the literal sense of concentration camp
here is the resurrection and the life
said the automobile industry here is
the indestructibility of matter observe the
philosophy of reincarnation in the fiery furnace
what was once a sheet of Steel and became
a car returns to its maker and
becomes a game a sheet of steel
and consequently once again a car it will
be the same car only different it will be
this year's car instead of last year's car
it will be a little bigger a little smarter
and blue tiara it will add minimally
to the costly congestion of America
but the cycle will be complete
the endless appetite of carnivorous America
demands a rationalization even
of the Bleak business of butchery
and here a snag arises in the
old social rhythm for the more
efficient every process becomes
the more men it can do with that
even the mechanical reduction of flesh
to food needs fewer and fewer men all
the time it still needs craftsmen of
a kind but fewer than last year and
next year will mean fewer still
and the following year who knows
see
wish adequacy
nation sweeping the nation in adventure which
is one let me reads his legacy it was done by a
thousand computers twenty years ago there wasn't
even a name for today the computers haunt and
dominate the whole American industrial scene the
super efficient mindless masters of mechanics
the computers servitors even have a
new labor classification witnesses
they don't do any work they watch the
work being done they may have the air
of scholars but all that job requires as
a high school diploma and 21 days training
in every University of America the question
of automation is becoming obsessive with
the population of the world increasing almost
doubling within the next 30 or 40 years when
it seemed better really to hold back automation
because of the unemployment problem what are we
gonna do with all the unemployed people in the
United States do you think Columbus is keeping
up with the changing times of unemployment or do
you think would be hard or ahead the rest of the
big cities in the United States where automation
never take the place of the doctor or the lawyer
even now this creeping fear of the Machine is
starting a reaction of anxiety clean through
the United States America is a place where new
ideas easily get out of control could they have
exaggerated the threat of this takeover bid by
the computers one of the great computer experts
is Paul Armour I don't think that we really know
the limit to which machines can take over tasks
from men I suspect that that rather than our
being surprised by finding some sort of a limit
that we'll be surprised to find out what things
they can do which today we say they'll never be
able to do I'm one of the the optimist about
machines abilities yes as far as the ordinary
layman can grasp the theory of computers it would
seem that they are basically simple things that
have to be instructed in simple terms I think
this notion that the computer is nothing but
an adding machine is quite wrong the machine
is basically a symbol manipulator and it was
just sort of historical accident that the first
symbols that we chose to have it work with were
numeric ones but today there is much research
in what is sometimes called the the simulation
of human cognition research which attempts to
learn more about the mental activity of human
beings how they process information the computer
therefore may be limited only by our ability to
put it to work perhaps it could who knows be
developed to a point where it could in fact
learn its own skills I think that one of the
other notions you hear about machines is that
they're very stupid and they only do exactly
what they're told to do and this is quite true
but the people who are saying this don't seem to
realize that what is the limit on what they can
be told to do can they be told to learn to do
something I think they can wh Fetty is a social
philosopher at the Center for Democratic Studies
at Santa Barbara I believe within the lifetimes
of all of my associates myself most of the work
of most of the people will be done by machines
I agree to that portion of how we will exchange
the present society for a new society is the hard
question for all of us within our lifetime he
said so how fast is this revolution coming how
much time has a medical got to prepare dr. Ralph
bellman is another leading computer man I think
that the basic question is this can a Democratic
Society stand the strain of having large numbers
of people out of work and therefore uncommitted
to our systems this is the basic problem so the
question is what are we going to do with these
people how are we going to employ them and how
are we going to employ them let's say within the
framework of a capitalistic system this is surely
the real crunch of the automated revolution the
fact that it's starting in the one country that
sets an almost mystical value on work and
its reward United States is certainly the
most automated society at the present time it
will be the most automated Society for as far
as we can see into the future yet simultaneously
the United States is the strongest upholder of
the Protestant ethic it is the country where the
Puritan tradition is strongest where it is held
that work is absolutely essential that man is not
contributing to society unless he works now the
question is how can a society which believes in
this very strongly how can it face the cultural
political and social implications of automation
where there may not be enough physical work
must be kicked around stuff to have anyway
they want to do was waking up boys whose time
was moving out and let's get what's do what the
bosses call enhanced gross national production
isn't much help to the worker who's now not
needed to produce even three years ago this
was a an almost unknown topic it was a topic that
never got into the center of the dialogue at all
now it's almost the chief domestic issue this
country faced with this dire automation problem
America reacts with a slogan word retraining
the official circles have a lot of faith in the
belief that as a man has automated out of one
job he could be trained for another also that
people can move from production industries to the
public services Peter Max is a notable industrial
economist I believe it is true that with friction
and with slippage the system just as it has been
adjusting and people who were previously employed
in the manufacture of goods will now become
employed in the provision of services now this
is not any kind of a drastic change in terms of
distributing income and problems of that sort it
means that people as time goes on have different
livelihoods or different occupations if you will
than they have had before they will be providing
services rather than manufacturing product already
the service occupations in America have been built
up more than anywhere else but can they possibly
absorb everyone who is automated out of industry
Michael Harrington is a celebrated authority
on the problems Automation brings well first
of all given the figures we have of the potential
of automation to displace people there simply are
not enough of the personal service occupations
to allow that to take up the slack secondly up
until now services have not been automated but
they can be there is evidence now that there's
going to be an automated department store in
which there will be no salespeople you'll do
the entire thing by machines the grocery companies
are in these supermarkets are working on automated
checkout lines where they'll dispense with the
checkout people many of these occupations can be
automated it's already a pattern that the kind
of work is needed in the future will be very
different from the familiar image of the working
man I suspect that we're at the point now were
is it doesn't make very much sense to retrain
some people because it is so difficult to train
retrain some of these people the jobs which are
going unfulfilled today are primarily jobs which
require a higher degree of native intellect
than these peoples than many of these people
who we might consider retraining the percentage
of people who can be retrained I think is much
smaller than the percentage of people who need to
be retained I regard these programs of retraining
and replacement as sort of last-ditch stands
against a new kind of world world it's novel
in all of its aspects we all of all people
I suppose not only Americans but all people
resist the new there is no such thing as a good
new idea they're only good old ideas and so we
cling to old ideas as long as we can is it really
true in the de medica we'll just have to face the
fact as all developed countries will that work is
on its way out that answer to the problem really
misses the heart of it because the heart of it is
all right once you've done that once you imagine
as we now can with our technology literally an
abundant world one says Paul docker gave the
French poet as said the world is finished once
the Faustian experience is over you've made it
what then do you do and therefore I think that
this answer of the service industry least the
social service although certainly quite relevant
now in something that America and any abundant
society must do that answer avoids this basic
question of we are in the future at some point
going to have a technology in which people
will not have to work as we have defined work
traditionally what are we going to substitute for
that work as an activity and how are these people
going to consume how are they going to gain their
title to consumption if they don't do it through
could it actually be the tamerica where work and
reward are especially sacred will one day have to
pay people for just being people pay them not
produce but to consume in such a country could
it even be contemplated whether some people have
proposed the United States you simply send people
a check which is one way of handling another way
which curiously has been proposed by an economic
advisor to Senator Barry Goldwater is that we have
a negative income tax in the United States that at
the end of the year you send in a report to the
government on how much money you made if you made
over X amount of dollars you pay attacks to the
government if you make under X amount of dollars
the government pays attacks to you to bring
it up to X this conservative economist says
that this can be done quite simply through the tax
system and you could say all right five thousand
dollars a year everybody shall have it so if you
only make three thousand you send your tax into
the government they send you a check for $2,000 I
don't want to minimize the difficulty but I think
means can be found to transfer consumption titles
ie money to citizens it isn't just a question of
monkeying around a little bit with sociologists
on one side and they copy econometrics on another
this requires a wholly new view of what society
is what it ought to be what its possibilities are
the willingness for people to try to take hold of
their own destinies and invent new institutions to
take hold of their own destinies and work out a
decent world after all all of the Western world
has been sort of consecrated to this notion
of hard work and relation of work to incomes
and the automaticity of the whole procedure that
everything would sort of automatically fall into
place if you just kept the machinery going it
isn't working that way the circles been broken
it's very hard for us to imagine a society not
dedicated to getting and spending so when the
possibility comes before us of in effect taking
the economic machine from the middle of the room
and putting it over on the side getting it out of
the way so people have some living room something
to do with themselves is human being great shouts
of a lion go up all over the all over the place I
think for many years we've seen human beings
sacrifice to this faceless god of efficiency
and it's about time that we now realize that the
basic problem is that of the human being he is
what counts not the machine not the question of
efficiency but whether the meeting human needs
whether human beings are happy the kind world
I'm talking about is not one in which work has
been eliminated it's a world in which work has
been substantially redefined James Thurber once
said that his hardest task was to convince his
wife that he was working when he was looking out
of the window well they're going to be a lot of
looking out of the window down in the future well
an interesting point here is that an Englishman
was one of the first prophets of abundance and
John Maynard Keynes and Keynes said precisely
that when this period of abundance comes vices
that we have called Brook shoes such as seeking
money will be seen as the vices they are or and
mankind will then be able to get on with decent
occupations so I think that this a change in the
value system a profound change in the value
system will take place are we going to make
sure that every citizen of this country gets
a fair share of all this wealth are we going
to make sure that he has his place in the Sun but
he's taken care of are we going to make sure that
everybody around the world gets their fair share
these are the basic problems of our computerised
society I don't think it's going to be easy at
all on paper it's quite simple we've got this
enormous production we will have an increase
in production and theoretically on paper we
can simply apply that production to the needs of
people without reference to whether they work or
not the only difficulty there is psychological
political social religious because to do that is
to change the very basis of American society
we've believed for years decades since our
beginning that it is through hard work that a
man establishes his worth as a human being is
worth in the eyes of his neighbor and even
in the Protestant ethic is worth in the eyes
of God and when you talk about changing that
you're talking about changing some of the most
fundamental assumptions of American society so
I would say in in chart yes it is quite easy if
American society will have a revolution in its
thinking but that revolution is quite difficult
I think for the first time in human history we
can do anything we want we can produce anything
we want we can give every citizen everything he
wants if we want so the primary question is what
do we really want what is it that will really
make us happy that is the basic question who
are we I think the United States is pretty well
lost now it isn't just a sort of accident that
Commission's have been stumbling around the
United States looking under bushels for the
national purpose it isn't an accident that most
observers now characterize the United States
as a country greatly afflicted by anomie
alienation and all those other fashionable words
to say to describe a person or an institution
that's come unstuck I'm not at all sure we're
going to make it because as you indicate the
change is so extremely fast that the thought
is going to have to run very fast to catch up
with it and we've hardly begun I don't see the
motive for our thinking so radically abundance
seems to create a certain kind of complacency
rather than an ability for candid thought perhaps
we won't do it perhaps we will be and will be
one of the greatest paradoxes in history brass
will be victimized by our creation of abundance
it isn't given to every nation to be
threatened with ruin through riches to
be a society potentially in mortal danger
from its own prosperity nobody ever faced
this paradox before and it's affording a people
so resilient and so flexible in so much and now
so desperately at a loss to know how to cope
with the looming peril of the golden aid the
American working citizens may soon be made
entirely of transistors but brainless forces
ready to emancipate the human American from all
he really wants his own value his own usefulness
and pride he faces his liberation with that
and even fear it would be a strange fate to
be invented into oblivion to find the work
at an end because indeed the night had come